est aujourd'hui plus élevée, en 2016,
qu'en 1890, il y a 125 ans,
et elle a augmenté pendant presque toutes les décennies
pendant ces 125 ans.
C'est paradoxal.
Nos machines font de plus en plus notre travail.
Pourquoi cela ne rend-il pas
notre travail inutile, nos compétences obsolètes ?
Pourquoi y a-t-il encore tant d'emplois ?
(Rires)
Je vais tenter de répondre à cette question
et ce faisant, je vais vous dire
ce que cela implique pour l'avenir du travail
et les problèmes que l'automatisation pose et ne pose pas
à notre société.
Pourquoi y a-t-il tant d'emplois ?
Deux principes économiques fondamentaux sont en jeu.
L'un d'entre eux a à voir avec le génie humain
et la créativité.
L'autre a à voir avec l'insatiabilité humaine,
ou la cupidité, si vous voulez.
Je vais appeler le premier le principe O-Ring,
il touche au type de travail que nous faisons.
Le second est le principe du jamais-assez,
il affecte le nombre existant d'emplois.
Commençons par le principe O-Ring.
Les distributeurs de billets
ont deux effets compensateurs sur l'emploi des guichetiers.
Comme attendu, ils ont remplacé des tâches de guichetier.
Le nombre de guichetiers par agence a baissé d'un tiers.
Mais les banques ont rapidement vu
qu'il coûtait moins cher d'ouvrir des agences
et le nombre d'agences bancaires a augmenté de presque 40%
dans le même temps.
Le résultat net : plus d'agences et plus de guichetiers.
Mais ces guichetiers faisaient un travail un peu différent.
Dans leurs fonctions, la gestion des espèces a décru,
ils sont devenus moins comme des caissiers
et plus comme des commerciaux,
établissant des relations avec les clients,
résolvant des problèmes,
présentant de nouveaux produits
comme les cartes de crédit, prêts, investissements :
plus de guichetiers faisant un boulot plus exigeant cognitivement.
Il y a un principe général ici.
Le travail que nous faisons
exige de multiples compétences,
du cerveau et des muscles,
une expertise technique et de l'intelligence intuitive,
de la sueur et de l'inspiration, pour citer Thomas Edison.
En général, automatiser quelques éléments de ces tâches
ne rend pas les autres inutiles.
En fait, ça les rend plus importantes.
Ça augmente leur valeur économique.
Je vous donne un exemple affligeant.
En 1986, la navette spatiale Challenger
a explosé et s'est écrasée
moins de 2 minutes après le décollage.
Il s'avère que la cause du crash
était un anneau de caoutchouc peu coûteux sur la fusée porteuse
qui avait gelé sur la rampe de lancement la nuit précédente
et a lâché dramatiquement quelques instants après le décollage.
Dans cette organisation multimilliardaire,
ce simple anneau de caoutchouc
a fait la différence entre le succès de la mission
et la mort dévastatrice de sept astronautes.
Une métaphore ingénieuse de cet événement tragique
est la fonction de production de type O-Ring,
définie par l'économiste Michael Kremer, de Harvard,
après la catastrophe Challenger.
La fonction de production de type O-ring conçoit le travail
comme une série d'étapes entrelacées,
de maillons d'une chaîne.
Chacun de ces maillons doit tenir pour que la mission réussisse.
Si l'un d'entre eux échoue,
la mission, le produit ou le service
s'effondre.
Cette situation précaire a une implication étonnamment positive,
qui est que les améliorations
dans la fiabilité de chaque maillon dans la chaîne
augmente la valeur de l'amélioration de tous les autres maillons.
Concrètement, si la plupart des maillons sont fragiles et peuvent casser,
le fait que votre maillon n'est pas si fiable
n'est pas si important.
Quelque chose cassera probablement.
Mais si tous les autres maillons deviennent robustes et fiables,
l'importance de votre maillon devient essentielle.
À la limite, tout en dépend.
La raison pour laquelle l'anneau O-Ring était critique pour Challenger
est parce que tout le reste fonctionnait parfaitement.
Si la navette avait été une sorte d'équivalent
de Microsoft Windows 2000 --
(Rires)
un anneau défectueux n'aurait pas eu d'importance
parce que la machine aurait planté.
(Rires)
Voici une vision plus large.
Dans une bonne part du travail que nous faisons, nous sommes les anneaux.
Oui, les distributeurs de billets peuvent remplir certaines tâches
plus vite et mieux que les guichetiers,
mais cela ne les a pas rendus superflus.
Ça a accru l'importance de leur capacité à résoudre des problèmes
et à entrer en relation avec les clients.
Le même principe s'applique si nous construisons un immeuble,
si nous faisons un diagnostic, soignons un patient
ou donnons un cours
à une classe remplie de lycéens.
Si nos outils s'améliorent,
la technologie amplifie notre force
et accroît l'importance de notre expertise,
de notre jugement, de notre créativité.
Et cela me mène au second principe :
en vouloir toujours plus.
Vous pensez peut-être : « OK, O-Ring, j'ai pigé,
ça veut dire que les boulots que font les gens seront importants.
Des machines ne les font pas, mais il faut toujours les faire.
Mais ça ne me dit pas combien d'emplois seront nécessaires. »
N'est-ce pas une sorte d'évidence
qu'une fois devenus assez productifs à une tâche,
notre travail supprime notre emploi ?
En 1900, 40% des emplois américains
étaient agricoles.
Aujourd'hui, c'est moins de 2%.
Pourquoi y a-t-il si peu de fermiers ?
Ce n'est pas que nous mangeons moins.
(Rires)
Un siècle de gains de productivité dans l'agriculture
veut dire que deux millions de fermiers
peuvent nourrir une nation de 320 millions.
C'est un progrès extraordinaire,
mais ça veut aussi dire
qu'il reste peu d'emplois de type O-Ring dans l'agriculture.
Donc, clairement, la technologie peut éliminer des emplois.
L'agriculture n'est qu'un exemple.
Il y en a beaucoup d'autres.
Mais ce qui est vrai pour un produit, un service ou une industrie
n'a jamais été vrai pour l'économie tout entière.
Nombre d'industries où nous travaillons maintenant --
la santé et la médecine,
les finances et les assurances,
l'électronique et l'informatique --
étaient modestes ou n'existaient pas il y a un siècle.
De nombreux produits auxquels nous consacrons notre argent --
l'air conditionné, les 4x4,
les ordinateurs, téléphones mobiles --
coûtaient extrêmement cher
ou n'avaient pas encore été inventés il y a cent ans.
Alors que l'automatisation libère notre temps, étend nos possibilités,
nous inventons de nouveaux produits, idées, services
qui focalisent notre attention,
occupent notre temps
et poussent à la consommation.
Vous pourriez penser que quelques-unes de ces choses sont frivoles --
le yoga extrême, le tourisme d'aventure,
Pokémon GO --
et je pourrais en convenir.
Mais les gens veulent ces choses et travaillent dur pour les acheter.
En 2015, le travailleur moyen
qui voudrait atteindre le niveau de vie moyen de 1915
pourrait le faire en ne travaillant que 17 semaines par an,
un tiers du temps.
Mais les gens ne choisissent pas cette vie.
Ils veulent travailler dur
pour obtenir la prime technologique à leur disposition.
L'abondance matérielle n'a jamais éliminé le manque perçu.
Dans les mots de l'économiste Thorstein Veblen,
l'invention est mère de la nécessité.
Maintenant...
Si vous acceptez ces deux principes,
le principe O-Ring, le principe jamais-assez,
alors on est d'accord :
il y aura des emplois.
Ça voudrait dire qu'il ne faut pas s'inquiéter ?
L'automatisation, l'emploi, les robots et les boulots,
tout ça s'organisera tout seul ?
Non.
Ce n'est pas mon raisonnement.
L'automatisation crée de la richesse
en nous permettant de faire plus de travail, plus vite.
Il n'y a pas de loi économique
qui dit que nous utiliserons bien cette richesse
et on peut s'en inquiéter.
Considérez deux pays,
la Norvège et l'Arabie Saoudite.
Deux nations riches de pétrole,
c'est comme si elles avaient de l'argent jaillissant d'un trou dans le sol.
(Rires)
Mais elles n'ont pas utilisé cette richesse
également pour la promotion de la prospérité humaine,
une humanité prospère.
La Norvège est une démocratie florissante.
Dans l'ensemble, ses citoyens travaillent et se divertissent ensemble.
Elle est généralement classée entre la 1ère et la 4ème place
dans les palmarès du bonheur national.
L'Arabie Saoudite est une monarchie absolue
où de nombreux citoyens manquent d'une voie vers l'avancement personnel.
Elle est généralement classée 35ème parmi les nations en terme de bonheur,
ce qui est bas pour une nation si riche.
Juste pour comparer,
les États-Unis sont généralement vers la 12ème ou la 13ème place.
La différence entre ces deux pays
n'est pas leur richesse
ni leur technologie.
C'est leurs institutions.
La Norvège a investi dans la construction d'une société
avec des opportunités et une mobilité économiques.
L'Arabie Saoudite a élevé le niveau de vie
tout en entravant bien d'autres aspirations humaines.
Deux pays, tous deux riches,
différemment aisés.
Et cela m'amène au défi que nous affrontons aujourd'hui,
le défi que nous pose l'automatisation.
Ce n'est pas la disparition des emplois.
Les États-Unis ont créé 14 millions d'emplois
depuis les tréfonds de la Grande Dépression.
Le défi est que beaucoup de ces emplois
ne sont pas bons
et beaucoup de citoyens ne peuvent pas atteindre les bons boulots
qui sont créés.
La croissance de l'emploi aux États-Unis et dans le monde développé
ressemble à une haltère
avec un poids s'accroissant à chaque extrémité de la barre.
D'un côté,
vous avez l'enseignement supérieur, les salaires élevés
comme les médecins et les infirmières, les programmeurs et les ingénieurs,
le marketing, la direction commerciale.
Le marché de l'emploi est solide pour eux, en croissance.
De la même façon, le marché est solide pour de nombreux emplois
peu qualifiés, avec peu d'études comme la restauration,
le nettoyage, la sécurité,
les soins à domicile.
Simultanément, le marché se réduit
dans les emplois à éducation moyenne, au salaire moyen, de la classe moyenne,
comme pour les cols bleus de la production ou des services
et les cols blancs de l'administration et des ventes.
Les raisons derrière cette contraction
ne sont pas mystérieuses.
Nombre de ces emplois moyens
utilisent des règles et procédures bien comprises
qui peuvent de plus en plus être transformées en code
et exécutées par des ordinateurs.
Le défi que pose ce phénomène,
nommé par les économistes « polarisation de l'emploi »,
c'est qu'il réduit les barreaux de l'échelle économique,
réduit la taille de la classe moyenne
et menace de rendre notre société plus stratifiée.
D'un côté, un groupe de professionnels largement payés, très éduqués,
au boulot intéressant ;
de l'autre, de nombreux citoyens mal payés
dont la responsabilité principale
est de veiller au confort et à la santé des riches.
Ce n'est pas ma vision du progrès
et je doute que ce soit la vôtre.
Mais voici des nouvelles encourageantes.
Nous avons déjà connu des transformations économiques aussi considérables
et nous les avons surmontées avec succès.
À la fin du XIXe siècle, au début du XXe,
quand l'automatisation éliminait un grand nombre d'emplois dans l'agriculture, --
vous vous souvenez de ce tracteur ? --
les États agricoles ont fait face à un chômage de masse,
une génération de jeunes dont on n'avait plus besoin à la ferme
mais non préparés pour l'industrie.
Relevant ce défi,
ils ont pris la mesure radicale
d'exiger que toute leur population jeune
reste à l'école et poursuive son éducation
jusqu'à l'âge avancé de 16 ans.
On a appelé ça le mouvement des lycées
et c'était une chose très coûteuse à faire.
Non seulement il fallait construire des écoles,
mais ces jeunes ne pouvaient pas travailler.
Cela s'est aussi révélé un des meilleurs investissements
des États-Unis durant le XXe siècle.
Cela a donné la main-d'œuvre la plus qualifiée, la plus flexible
et la plus productive du monde.
Pour voir comment ça a réussi, imaginez prendre la main-d'œuvre de 1899
et la transposer dans le présent.
Malgré leur dos solide et leur bon caractère,
les compétences de base en lecture et calcul manqueraient à beaucoup
pour faire autre chose que les boulots les plus banals.
Nombre d'entre eux seraient inemployables.
Ce que montre cet exemple est la primauté de nos institutions,
plus particulièrement nos écoles,
en nous permettant de récolter les fruits
de notre prospérité technologique.
Il serait naïf de dire qu'il n'y a rien à craindre.
Clairement, on peut se planter.
Si les États-Unis n'avaient pas investi dans leurs écoles et compétences
il y a cent ans, avec le mouvement des lycées,
nous serions bien moins prospères,
moins mobiles et, probablement, aurions une société moins heureuse.
Mais il est aussi naïf de dire que le destin est scellé.
Des machines n'en décident pas.
Pas même les marchés.
C'est nous et nos institutions qui en décidons.
J'ai commencé cette conférence sur un paradoxe.
Nos machines font de plus en plus de travail pour nous,
pourquoi ça ne rend-il pas notre travail inutile,
nos compétences obsolètes ?
N'est-il pas évident que la route vers notre enfer économique et social
est pavée de nos propres grandes inventions ?
L'Histoire a plusieurs fois donné une réponse à ce paradoxe.
La première partie de la réponse est que la technologie augmente notre force,
l'importance, la valeur ajoutée
de notre expertise, de nos jugements, de notre créativité.
C'est le principe O-Ring.
La seconde partie de la réponse est l'inventivité infinie,
nos désirs sans fond,
qui font que nous n'en avons jamais assez.
Il y a toujours un nouveau travail à faire.
L'ajustement au rythme rapide des évolutions technologiques
crée de vrais défis,
clairement identifiés dans notre marché du travail polarisé
et la menace qu'il oppose à la mobilité économique.
Relever ce défi n'est pas automatique,
n'est pas gratuit,
n'est pas facile,
mais c'est faisable.
Voici des nouvelles encourageantes.
Du fait de notre productivité extraordinaire,
nous sommes riches.
Bien sûr, nous pouvons investir dans nous-mêmes et nos enfants
comme l'a fait l'Amérique il y a cent ans avec le mouvement des lycées.
Alors, nous ne pouvons pas ne pas le faire.
Vous pensez peut-être
que le professeur Autor vous a raconté une histoire touchante
sur le passé lointain,
le passé récent,
peut-être le présent, mais probablement pas l'avenir.
Parce que chacun sait que cette fois, c'est différent.
D'accord ? Est-ce que cette fois est différente ?
Bien sûr, cette fois, c'est différent.
Chaque fois, c'est différent.
À de nombreuses reprises depuis 200 ans,
les universitaires et les militants ont sonné l'alarme
disant que nous perdions des emplois en nous rendant obsolètes :
par exemple, les luddites, au début du XIXe siècle ;
le ministre américain du travail, James Davis,
au milieu des années 20 ;
le prix Nobel d'économie Wassily Leontief en 1982 ;
et bien sûr de nombreux universitaires,
experts, technologues,
personnalités médiatiques aujourd'hui.
Ces prévisions me paraissent arrogantes.
Ces oracles auto-proclamés disent en fait :
« Si je ne peux imaginer ce que feront les gens comme travail à l'avenir,
alors vous, moi et nos enfants
ne l'imaginerons pas non plus. »
Je n'ai pas l'audace
de prendre ce pari contre l'inventivité de l'homme.
Je ne peux pas vous dire ce que les gens auront comme travail
dans cent ans.
Mais le futur ne dépend pas de mon imagination.
Si j'avais été un fermier de l'Iowa en 1900
et qu'un économiste du XXIe siècle, s'était téléporté dans mon champ
et m'avait dit : « Eh, tu sais quoi, Autor le fermier,
dans les cent prochaines années,
l'emploi agricole passera de 40% de tous les emplois
à 2%
juste avec la hausse de la productivité.
Que penses-tu que les autres 38% de travailleurs feront ? »
Je n'aurais pas répondu : « Oh, je sais.
On développera des apps, fera de la médecine radiologique,
des cours de yoga, du Bitmoji. »
(Rires)
Je n'en aurais rien su.
Mais j'espère que j'aurais eu l'esprit de dire :
« Wahou, une réduction de 95% de l'emploi agricole,
sans pénurie alimentaire.
C'est un sacré progrès.
J'espère que l'humanité trouvera quelque chose de remarquable à faire
de toute cette prospérité. »
Et dans l'ensemble, je dirais que cela a été le cas.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)